and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week daylight
saving time how is this still a thing if
you're like most Americans
you've been groggy all day after losing
an hour of sleep to daylight saving and
as you struggle to remember how to
change the clock on your King microwave
you may have wondered why is this
happening for years conventional wisdom
has been that it benefits one particular
group I know it started because of
farmers I'm almost sure that but that's
not actually true
it gives them extra time to plant extra
time to the harvest it has nothing to do
with farmers I remember Liz ago hearing
that it was for the farm people the
foreign people want nothing to do with
this as they themselves will tell you I
know really no farmer that I'm aware of
that benefits from from you know
actually farm activities
I'm daylight saving time of course
daylight saving doesn't benefit farmers
cows don't care what time it is because
their cows and cows are idiots so if
it's not for them who is it for
the modern daylight saving was
introduced during the first world war as
a fuel saving measured by the Germans
that's right you lost an hour of sleep
this morning thanks to Kaiser Wilhelm
and while back then daylight saving may
indeed have saved fuel in the modern era
energy consumption is a little more
complicated in fact when Indiana adopted
daylight saving in 2006 guess what
happened the data shows that daylight
saving actually led to a 1% overall rise
in residential electricity of course it
did because switching on a lamp an hour
later in the summer
doesn't really matter when you're
blasting an air conditioner and staying
up all night psychotically scrolling
through instagrams of your ex's
honeymoon to Morocco but that's not to
say daylight saving doesn't have any
effects at all studies show there is an
increase of car accidents and
work-related injuries the week after the
time change that's right what you lose
in sleep you
in mortal danger despite all this 70
countries around the world still observe
daylight saving and yet by going by
local news reports none of them could
tell you why from Australia well dialect
savings almost over for another year and
with it comes the usual debate over its
merits or lack thereof to Italy it's a
pain in the ass basically - even the
Germans the people who started this
whole mess
it's a feeling the time change for many
people is ridiculous whether it's an
hour ahead or later is complete nonsense
complete nonsense and that's coming from
a country that thinks this is a word and
that this is dancing so if it doesn't
benefit our energy bill our health or
our stupid stupid cows it has to make
you wonder daylight saving time how is
this still a thing
you